but remember last year the magazine
really made international headlines when
they put size 22 model test holiday on
the cover and I feel like that really
started a conversation about body image
in Hollywood but a year later has
anything really changed I was really
happy that they put me on the cover in a
sheer bodysuit and like didn't hide my
body that alone was a huge step and
there's more conversation around what
body positivity is and accepting and you
know people for who they are so I feel
like things are changing the feedback
you got from that cover was the majority
of it positive I had a quite a few
celebrities reach out to me Ricki Lake
Amber Riley Nia Tyler it was really nice
to see the unity in people reaching out
to me and saying that they appreciated
seeing something like dot Tess is
pregnant with her second child she's
been posting pictures of her growing
baby bump and the haters on the web came
out in full force what is it about body
shaming now it almost feels like it's
become the thing for people to do I
really don't care if people think that
I'm unhealthy you're promoting something
I feel like it's so clear that our
bodies our business and it's okay to be
who you want to be and to live on
apologetically and I feel like most
people get that they do read the
comments sometimes I do see what people
say her baby's due in a few weeks and
even though Tess is a larger woman she
says she still looks after her health
when you go to the doctor it does your
doctor say
Tess you're a healthy woman I literally
saw my OB yesterday and everything was
fine my baby was fine he said that he
couldn't be happier I'm fine I'm healthy
and we cannot wait till that baby's here
tests